tim made a good point last night when we
were talking about some of the
republicans not
being there for trump like that they're
just using him to get supreme court
nominees get a look get a few things and
then see him happy to see him go
and now they've packed the will not pack
the court but got some republicans in
there
some conservatives i guess you would
call them which republicans aren't even
necessarily conservative
anymore trump's always been fighting the
establishment on the right establishment
on the left and in fact trump
trump isn't we the network
the network of people tired of the
uniparty tired
of the corporatist tired of the globals
we are the ones that launched trump
it wasn't that trump was some amazing
politician and he's like some amazing
orator
it's that we picked him and we
catapulted him
grassroots effort people donating their
time and energy and
you know becoming part of this whole
movement it's a movement that launched
donald trump to the top
and whatever happens to donald trump
that movement's still going to be there
right and that movement is
against an ant you know anti towards the
establishment so establishment hates
trump hates all of us and wants to see
us
all squashed and it's not just the idea
of establishment it's this specific
establishment
that's like been corrupted by if it's a
global monetary obsession or like
this desire to prevent world war three
through military coercion
that's it's hi betsy it's this year it's
an improper
establishment that i think i'm against
anyway i'm not like anti-establishment
in general i just don't like this
current come on
you're wearing pajamas if we could build
an establishment if we could establish a
functional
you know you're not anti establishment
so that means your establishment
well if it's if you're not actively
anti-establishment sir
but i would like to establish something
valid
you know where the votes are tallied in
in plain sight where we can trust each
other wherever there's no war we're
you know the the the votes are tallied
in plain sight
the anomaly here is that specific votes
weren't tallied in plain sight well
they're
tallied on a computer program yes yes
yes and that's that's
part of it proprietary one oh here she
comes so we have a we have a full hand
recount coming in georgia
yeah we do now is is that a recount or
is that a re-canvas or is that an
everything that the they're going to
look at each ballot secretary of state
said
everything he said re uh uh recount
re uh uh a recount an audit and a
re-canvas oh boom there you go
we'll see some people are saying they're
still gonna after they segregate them
run them through the scanners
but look man it's always been insane
that we use proprietary software
to to do our elections it should be open
source and the code should be available
on the web
and we should be able to load up that
code in real time as they're sliding
those ballots in
we can all watch yes the only reason
they would want to hide anything is
because
days of cheating open source is safer in
many instances right because people get
to test it
it's not so much about like you wouldn't
be able to
i guess one of the challenges is that
you can't these machines aren't supposed
to be connected to the internet at all
and therein lies a serious problem if
they are they can be exploited remotely
but if they aren't then they can be
exploited before
and then activate the exploits after so
it's we had this glitch in michigan
and the company is saying no no it was
human error the the six thousand votes
that went
that were for for trump but went to
biden i was that was human error
but we're seeing similar numbers across
the board
so you think that if trump is the one
that rejects the outcome
certified outcome constitutional outcome
that the
one of the first signs that we would see
is what total shutdown of all social
media
yeah well i think in any capacity like
i don't know if we're ever gonna get
anywhere near that but i'll put it this
way before we get into like
this like really out there conversation
oh
we're talking about uh trump going to
war out there let me just say
warning there was a period on saturday
when they called it for joe biden
where it seemed like everybody just
agreed joe biden wins
and there were trump supporters who
seemed to be stopping and looking around
to check the temperature
there were uh certain personalities i
won't name who are kind of like
not you know are we fighting this or not
right right right right yeah who
do are we all just going to lay down and
let them let them run in or are we going
nuts
and then now you can see i don't wanna i
don't wanna call anybody out
specifically because i know there's a
lot of people who watch but um
some some tv people some tv
personalities really seemed like they
were gearing up for the for laying down
their sword
until they saw the likes of don jr and
people like sebastian gorka
and you know other high profile trump
supporting personalities went
charge then all of a sudden the fair
weather trump supporters were like yes
yes
yes of course we're waiting for their
queue yeah well they wanted to make sure
they weren't going to be jumping in with
the
with you know that makes sense yeah
unsupported so it's an information war
and you got to have all kinds of
information weapons and you have foot
soldiers and infantry and people in the
trenches
cross grass roots crowd source meme
makers influencers spontaneously
erupting uh you know canvassers and etc
and you need like artillery cover for
your ground troops man in an information
war and the way that you do that is by
getting out there in front and laying
down the narrative and then also
supporting people that are victims in
the information war which is something
that i've heard
as a criticism from the trump
administration that they did not protect
people who were victims in the infowar
and they should have done a better job
of that and it does make it hard to
attract quality people and retain
quality people if you're not going to
protect them
in this information scuffle but at least
don jr and them going
out big time was enough to just rally
the troops and have everybody go which
no matter what the outcome we have a
nation
worldwide open source intelligence
operation underway perhaps like nothing
we've ever seen before
comparable to covid but you know just in
a presidential election the first time
it's ever happened like this
and you know what if everybody's working
on it and they're all thinking about it
and the answer
is that he has lost i feel like
everybody
knowing that they've spent all their
powder
can accept that but not until then i
think at the very least we have to try
we have to make sure when accusations or
allegations come up we we we clear the
air because we're hyper-polarized
yeah so under normal circumstances if it
was like
you know if it was 2016 and hillary
started screaming about the russians
you know it's like okay you know we'll
we'll we'll entertain this
you know we'll look into it then they
went kind of nuts with it for several
years and now i'm like
hey if you're going to do the russian
thing we're going to do the vote fraud
thing end of story
exactly but ultimately the point is if
you're this polarized the last thing you
want to do is say we refuse to listen to
you
do as we say and submit exactly because
then people are going to be like
no there's there's a chance for
cooperation all right we heard you there
may be some fraud
we're going to treat this fairly we're
going to do a recount and an audit to
make sure that this is right and if you
lost accept it
and that really will defang any
aggression there will still be some
people who are like no
but ultimately that's what has to happen
but so they're not doing that though
right as don jr
set the tone for their network charge
yeah joe biden sets the tone for his
network saying off
office of the president-elect and just
running with it and starting to float
names for cabinets
etc so they're they're clearly not
taking the approach of
this is how it's supposed to be there's
a period for legal challenges and even
if that gets screwed up
hey it's written down and agreed to that
the state legislatures can slate
whatever electors that they want
basically
so like that's all normal it's unusual
but it's all legal it's all part of that
i don't even i don't think it's unusual
it's that the media has created this
perspective
for for a generation where it's we call
the election look what the new york
times tweeted
you see the new york times tweeted it's
the job of the media to call the
presidential election yeah i
screen capped that immediately knowing
that they were gonna delete that that
was insane
they're like only the media declares the
winner and we're going to explain how
thread you know like one slash x and
then
and then it got deleted real quick right
that's a good one this is this is normal
what's happening
there's an election they're tallying the
votes and they have not certified them
but the media has created a perspective
that it's supposed to be them who calls
it and when they do it's over
that's how it's always been uh we're in
charge trump says uh
we still have to certification the
normal process is the process in the
constitution
it is weird to me that we have a
contested election
even if it looks like trump is going to
lose and the media is saying shut up and
submit
stop saying this i look at cnn they ran
this
this video where they're like right wing
individuals putting out misinformation
that trump could still win
right it's it's crazy because it has
never been
this obvious i feel like we're watching
that cartoon character trying to plug
the holes in a ship
as the water is spraying through dude i
don't know if trump is going to win
the votes are in joe biden's favor but
the normal process is
legal challenges and trump has them so
at the very least you don't say
trump can't win well it's starting to
change though vox.com published an
article saying
um well it's uh not likely but
uh trump could win these ways and then
they list out like three different ways
trump could actually win
through a normal legal process not a
coup right
i can't remember any time in my lifetime
that the state legislatures have slated
electors that didn't reflect the will of
the people in their state
has that happened i mean if we if we go
back
to the 1800s there's weird elections
yeah like
we talked about a little bit the other
day this really weird election where it
was tied in the electoral college so
they just appointed a council
of democrats republicans judges and
lawyers or whatever to just like
convene and decide who the president
would be like a poop thing
and that's what they did and that's what
they did and they were like all right
well uh here we agree
and actually it the concession i believe
this ended
um the reconstruction era because
basically there was
they were they felt like they were on
the verge of another civil war so they
said okay okay
how about the presidency goes to the
republican but
we'll give you a bunch of stuff and they
said fine and then
that ended reconstruction yeah created a
democrat stronghold in the south for
generations to come and then that like
is ultimately what resolved this
but the interesting thing is apparently
there's like an artic an article that
says you know a trump a deal with trump
to leave the white house
trump doesn't carry don't want it yeah
like uh
there's rumors that they're you know
you'll be a king maker
you can run packs you can do all these
things once you leave and trump's like
no right i'm president right and do
do you think tim truly that even if it
goes all the way through all the courts
and everything and maybe
even gets it to the point where like a
decision could be made by the supreme
court that would affect the outcome
and it still doesn't fall his way you
think that when this
everything is exhausted what's he going
to do
trump yeah i don't know i don't know i
do he'll bow out
i don't know because uh because he's too
good of a person to screw things up like
that i think
i don't know i agree i don't i don't
think that he will stay on extra
an extra judicious way i don't know
what's going on behind illegally
yeah there's an article from the
washington post that says there's a
massive
behind-the-scenes effort to stop trump
right now
as if we didn't know that like like
they're they've been doing
this for years right the massive
behind-the-scenes effort to stop trump
at every cost
now they're saying it was i think
brennan said mike pence must invoke
article uh amendment 25 and remove trump
before he does something
it's like he's still the president right
but they're worried
don jr tweeted declassify at all so
please
do perfect right right right and they're
freaking out because
they've been trying to stop him at all
costs so here's the question
you look at russiagate you look at obama
gate and you look at these like this
very clear and terrifying
uh instances the evidence that's come
out so far i wouldn't say is definitive
proof like of a massive criminal
conspiracy but it's circumstantial
evidence that we need
probably a special prosecutor and a hard
investigation maybe what was it 27
million dollars or whatever to go
through it you have these notes from the
fbi saying what's our goal to get flynn
fired or prosecute
you have the the notes where they're
talking about you know joe biden
mentioning the logan act
they're doing what they're doing right
now what biden is doing right now is a
violation of the logan act
indeed joe biden is contacting foreign
government saying he's the president and
the election's not even over yet
we've got a certification and he's
calling foreign governments okay two
things one i've been seeing that clip
from the debates where wallace
asks them both point blank will you uh
you know
concede once the election has been
certified trump gives a long rambling
answer but in the middle he goes 100
but then he goes into this whole thing
about disputing anticipating this
and at the very end wallace asked by in
the very same question and biden goes
absolutely like he well that question
was more like will you wait to claim the
presidency or whatever until
certification is done and he said yes
and he's clearly not doing he's not
yeah the fact that he's putting together
a transition team the fact that he said
he doesn't need approval from the
government to do what he's doing
they went after michael flynn for the
logan act well they ultimately got him
online
but hold on let's back up earlier when
we were off the air you were mentioning
the fact that uh trump has instructed
his you know cabinet chiefs and and
folks to prepare the budgets as if he's
going to be president yeah that's the
same thing as
biden off opening the office of the
president-elect they're just
both they're both moving forward as if
they're going to be
the victors yeah the difference is trump
is within his legal right to tell them
prepare your budgets
for this coming you know season and
arguably by their own standard they
argued
joe michael flynn should not have been
contacting kislyak
the russian ambassador before he was
trump was inaugurated
he was only acting national security uh
advisor
therefore for joe biden right now to be
contacting foreign leaders and
discussing
i guess what he did was he contacted the
uk and said don't screw up the
you know a peace deal with ireland or
something like that over brexit
because now you know like i guess
ireland wants to go eu something like
that's going on
and immediately people seeing people
tweet out like biden just violated the
logan act lock them up i feel like they
bring up the logan act
every time there's a transition like
this and it's and it's and it's
ridiculous because it's not really a
violation we expect
the president-elect and his
administration to to start preparing for
you know entering office
yeah but they went after trump in this
way so anyway i bring this up because
if we're talking about a uh
i don't know what you'd call it a
conspiracy you know since the beginning
of the trump administration
to sabotage his his administration and
his presidency
and now they're actively trying to do it
again at what point do like
here's the conundrum you look at the
information we have available to us
if you only read or watch mainstream
news then you believe
everything's been fine russiagate was
fine it's too bad for trump
oopsie and then you know joe biden wins
the presidency
but if you are paying attention to the
bigger picture and you know about the
obama gate allegations and the evidence
that's been released
and you can see that these people have
been engaging in malicious activities
for quite some time
at what point do you say what they are
doing
what they are doing is the coup and not
trump well exactly and if you watch the
plot against the president a fantastic
movie uh directed by amanda milius a
former
trump political appointee daughter of
john milius
the director of apocalypse now
red dawn and a few others she laid out
a very compelling story showing how the
democrats have been screwing with trump
this whole time all the lies
all the plotting all the scheming all
everything and if you see that and you
watch it
and it's all based on documents that
were submitted to congress
right and testimony from people in
congress if you watch that then there's
absolutely no surprise
to see or think if someone says hey do
you think the democrats might try to
try to screw with the election it makes
perfect sense thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time